[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui on organisait une visite de
presse à paris saclay sur sur saint
quentin en yvelines et ensuite sur la
paris saclay en essonne donc sur le
campus urbain nous nous trouvons
actuellement pour montrer l'excellence
académique et l'excellence industrielle
que nous avons ici sur paris saclay et
parce que nous sommes six semaines avant
l'événement paris saclay spring qui est
notre grand rendez vous annuel de
l'innovation et donc l'idée c'était de
montrer aux journalistes ou en été paris
saclay en 2022 et puisqu'on va pouvoir
leur montrer le jour j ai donc le jour
de l'événement le 12 mai à paris saclay
sur le campus de l'école polytechnique
alors on avait axé notre présentation
sur la filière santé qui est une de nos
sept grandes filières d'excellence
industrielle à paris saclay la santé
c'est 40 % de nos startups aujourd'hui
ici sur le territoire donc aujourd'hui
on a présenté sky therapeutics qui est
une start up qui est actuellement un
cube est hébergé dans la faculté de
médecine de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines qui est une
des composantes de l'université paris
saclay et qui travaille sur la myopathie
de duchenne on a également ce matin en
fin de matinée présente et épi l'âme qui
travaille sur un appareil de diagnostic
rapide de la tuberculose qui est une
pandémie aujourd'hui un peu plus
silencieuse un peu moins visible mais
qui est toujours là et contre laquelle
il faut évidemment lutte et du mieux
possible et qui elle est incubé à
l'incubateur draps x de l'école
polytechnique donc voilà deux cas
d'école qui nous montre bien la richesse
de cet écosystème pour la santé
l'innovation en santé dans les
biotechnologies dans la pharmaceutique
notamment
sprint ce sera sa quatrième édition elle
12 et 13 mai prochains donc le 12 mai
sur le campus de l'école polytechnique
on aura à la fois un village des
villages d'exposition donc un showroom
technologique où on pourra découvrir les
prototypes les solutions les produits
d'une cinquantaine de start up qui ont
été sélectionnés on a créé un label pour
ça qu'ils s'appellent sprint 50 donc on
pourra à la fois avoir leur stand leurs
produits à la fois les ententes pitcher
dans un concours de pitch où elles
s'affrontent sueur le plateau télé qu'on
met en place pour l'événement donc ça ce
sera à la fin présentiel et à la fois
retransmis sur internet et puis
évidemment paris saclay springs est
avant tout une occasion de faire des
rencontres et donc c'est des rendez vous
d'affaires qui se déroule sur les deux
jours les 12 et 13 mai l'événement est
entièrement accessible à distance pour
ceux qui ne pourraient pas nous
rejoindre sauf la partie sur une
technologie qui elle est vraiment en
présentiel dans l'école polytechnique
[Musique]